and we have some breaking news coming in
China's annual parliamentary meeting has
been officially opened in Beijing and
it's expected that national security
legislation for Hong Kong will be
discussed during the seven day session
that's according to the Chinese state
news agency Xinhua the four proceedings
officially start on Friday now let's go
to phoebe Kong she has been following
this story for us and joins us from
Taiwan's capital Taipei Phoebe do you
have more details about this new law yes
you mentioned the chinese state media
just announced that the National
People's Congress which is a Chinese
parliament is going to these cuts the
new set of national security legislation
for Hong Kong so according to the
information we have and the reports from
the local media they released there was
some details of the legislation that the
new law may prohibit secession foreign
interference for foreign interference
and possibly terrorism so on these are
some so-called loopholes in Beijing's
eyes which they consider to be some
disadvantage of this closed during the
anti-government protests last year
happening in Hong Kong so they aim to
push for the new law to unplug such a
loopholes
you mentioned the anti-government
protests there what exactly what this
new law mean for Hong Kong and
especially the democracy movement there
to be frank this is indeed a bombshell
for not for Hong Kong but I'm sure for
the intentions secured out the
international community because of this
is highly controversial even more
controversial than the extradition bill
like sparked the protests last year so
on it's not only about the law itself
but also the procedure itself is very
controversial because according to the
information we have that Beijing is
planning to enact such legislation by
its own Holliman
then they will probably probably at
least the the the new causes under the
hong kong's mini constitution which is
the basic law so um in short then the
new legislation can be promulgated
automatically in Hong Kong without any
scrutiny of the local legislation so it
will simply bypass the scrutiny of the
also legislation so in our view that
this is going to spark a huge
controversy in Hong Kong again TV
briefly if you can have there been any
reactions to this in Hong Kong whilst
unless well the the the new the news
threat around the in Hong Kong society
people are very concerned about the new
legislation they fear that this would be
a further repression on the remaining
like free speech and the freedom of
expression because um they are worried
that a definition is not going to be
clear and it can be a true for the
regime and the authority or the police
to crack down on a political dissidence
our correspondent Phoebe Kong reporting
from Taipei thank you